and it was one week ago today that Lori
Lachlan and her husband Massimo pled
guilty in the College Admission scam
after fighting for more than a year a
lot of people were shocked that they
would give up but now we're learning why
a source tells ET Laurie feared the
absolute worst faced sleepless nights
and worried about spending years away
from her girls behind bars as the couple
face prison time Laurie's influenced her
daughter 20 year-old Olivia Jade shared
this makeup tutorial
her first Instagram feed post since her
parents entered their guilty plea turns
out according to our source Olivia and
her sister Isabella were vocal about the
plea deal and expressed their fears to
their parents and the urgency for this
to be over and for all of them to move
on but according to our source Laurie's
guilty plea is also about strategy quote
one of the main reasons Laurie finally
decided to take a plea is because of her
hope that she could possibly receive
house arrest during the pandemic
prosecutors however may have already
thought about that
I suspect in this case that they will
not surrender to prison until the
pandemic has passed I do not suspect
that they're gonna be able to serve the
sentence on home confinement because a
lot of people are speculating the full
house star and her fashion designer
husband Massimo Gio newly won't know for
sure where they'll serve until probably
their August sentencing he could serve
five months Laurie - if I were a betting
man I'd say Moss goes to Lompoc federal
prison camp and Laurie will go to
Victorville federal prison camp both in
Southern California
Laurie and Massimo will be sentenced on
August 21st
[Music]